an industry in crisis two of the world's
main Maritime routes disrupted
authorities have reduced traffic in the
Panama Canal a major Crossing between
Asia and the US by
36% because of a drought some companies
had planned to rout via the Red Sea but
that's become risky since houthi
fighters from Yemen started targeting
ships in response to Israel's war on
Gaza one trade analyst says the impact
on the global economy is important but
not catastrophic this is not the sort of
second coming of covid where we had all
of the shipping ports suddenly closed
overnight this is a localized problem
for which there are alternatives again
even if they cost more money and even if
they take more time they can be planned
for and planned around to avoid the Red
Sea ships have to take a longer route
past the southern tip of Africa adding
10 to 12 days to their Journey but
that's it's not always feasible
especially if the goods are perishable
if you talk about about the you know the
commodity which have shter shelf lives
the longer distance will definitely have
you know some fruits especially banana
boats and stuff it will be difficult for
them to reach on time um the the the
fruit will you know expire in a
particular time the Panama Canal and the
Su Canal are what's known as choke
points or pinch points narrow parts of
waterways which are recognized as
problem areas in global shipping routes
there are seven of them that have pinch
points that have been identified for a
very long time most firms have
Alternatives in place for what are we
going to do if and I think although
again disruptive unpleasant costs up
they can be managed because you can
start to forecast ahead of time however
the longer the houthi attacks continue
the bigger the disruption to
international trade Lawrence Louie Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer